that is absolutely a violation of the
spirit of the Constitution and basic
American rights and it's actually a
violation of the letter of the
Constitution in basic American rights so
if we want to play the game and try and
try and go back and forth with semantics
I don't know you're the party of the guy
who said eat and Chinatown and then the
next week said I will shut down churches
permanently unless you follow my every
order you have no leg to stand on it's
done we're not listening to you here's
the thing we want I want to talk about
New York because I think it meant not
only is New York obviously leading the
United States and in coronavirus flu
come flu Chinese virus we want to call
it cases and deaths and I it's not lost
on me that very idea of per capita that
something the media does by the way
right they say they said we have more
infections we have more infections and
deaths than any other country but then
all of a sudden when they say we don't
have enough testing right they use the
per capita we apply it to both it should
be because per capita guess we're not
even close to the countries they raise
Belgium France Sweden
I'm not Sweden Belgium France Spain
Italy definitely China significant on a
global scale at least a medical
researcher changeable really so keep an
eye on that because that does matter
sometimes you will see even in the same
article they'll reference infections
right and deaths total and then in the
very same paragraph they will reference
the the testing not being up to snuff we
have more tests than any other country
we don't have the best number of testing
per capita but it's actually a
significantly better number then you
look at the difference between a total
of deaths versus per capita test there's
a wider gap with those so you all know
that New York obvious New York they've
added a tremendous in a terrible way a
tragic number of deaths and raises right
they just passed everywhere else of
course in the codon petrus pass them but
it's just we just had a surgery but
here's what also matters they just added
3,700 deaths which sounds really bad
because you're here alone we've crested
we've hit the peak right we're
flattening the curve and they go more
deaths than ever in New York well
actually these deaths had never been
tested just to be clear we can bring it
up these are 3,700 S&P added sang
I'm now discovered that's Wow it seems a
bit strange and so think about that for
a second 3700 when you look at the total
desk I don't know at the time of this
broadcast it's somewhere between 28 and
29,000 I believe 3,700 could be a guess
your guess is as good as mine
that matters especially when you go okay
let's say 30,000 let's round it up let's
take away people who are over the age of
80 let's take away people of diabetes we
have serious heart conditions let's take
away all the ones that are just now mark
it down is Kelvin and guess what you are
left with an unbelievably small number
of deaths doesn't it does just don't
matter but it does matter in us gauging
the response and the accuracy of the
kind of aftermath that we'll have from
this decision let's be clear here
Governor Cuomo as much as I can't stand
his brother and we still have to have a
cage match with him he's actually been
getting along pretty well with with with
Donald Trump just surprised you have a
new sim where they've both been praising
each other aside from the barbell
nipples but come on these are mundane
details you can't stop our girl nipples
are not a mundane detail Michael but the
New York City Mayor and it's often easy
to forget because Giuliani was great and
then he had Bloomberg who was hysterical
and then you have two Blasio who's just
an assbag yes that he's the mayor of New
York City he's done the opposite of
Cuomo he is tried to pin all of this on
Donald Trump and I understand that
everyone everyone needs to there does
need to be some blame somewhere the buck
needs to stop somewhere I know how to
fix it moving forward but he's even gone
so far as to insinuate that Donald Trump
has killed people here you go
Chuck the president knighted States is
from New York City and he will not lift
a finger to help his hometown and I
don't get it Chuck I can't be blunt
enough if the president doesn't get
action from the president okay so let's
go through the time on here because I do
think that this matters
keep in mind Donald Trump restricted
travel right from China travel ban
whatever you want to call it January
31st okay of course it didn't really
take long for New York progressives to
spin it as racist and then yet city
officials telling people to attend the
Chinese Lunar
de Blasio not only this you see those
tweets de Blasio himself encouraged
people to eat in Chinatown in late
February and then you have Pelosi even
stopped by to promote like in let's be
honest you don't just stop by in
Chinatown they decided to stage a
photo-op after the travel ban in
Chinatown to gather and eat in public in
case you think I'm wearing should not
stop you from going about your life
should not stop you from going to
Chinatown and going out to eat I'm gonna
know that today myself it come to
Chinatown here we are we're again
careful safe and come join us three
things did it did anyone else know they
were all six inches from each other
right there hey what if his for purposes
of a photo op it's fine I just
III have done this show seldom and I am
I at a loss for words yeah I feel like
Chris Hansen when he showed up on that
pedophile was naked at McDonald's for
the second time I was just trying to get
something to eat they were encouraging
people to eat in Chinatown eat yeah
Chinatown let that sink in Chinatown
that's enough without the virus eat in
Chinatown let's keep this around here
most people I use Americans don't want
to eat in Chinatown you know you're safe
come on down low so this is this is what
really matters to me too is you can go
back and say that sure Donald Trump
could have taken actions earlier in some
specific instances understood certainly
not a perfect handling but each
in Chinatown long after the travel ban
you were you can go back and say well
they didn't get the supplies you
obviously weren't worried you were
telling everyone that they should just
go up go about their merry way that it's
no worse than the flu and that they
should all take the opportunity to eat
in Chinatown the Chinatown restaurant
tour is association right below see
here's some money right eat in Chinatown
Pelosi that should be hers II can't
write a song about that seems from a
Chinatown restaurant get the nc-17 Billy
Joel b-sides and no one wants that so
then a few days later after encouraging
people to eat in Chinatown first case
occurred and the spread began in
Manhattan on March 2nd while we're
talking about timelines here
de Blasio tweeted I wanna make sure I
get this right since I'm encouraging New
Yorkers March 2nd to go on with your
lives
plus the symbol plus I was blessed get
out on the town despite coronavirus I
thought I would offer some suggestions
beyond eating in China here's the 1st
through Thursday is this I'm from season
March 5th
ok it's March 5th I couldn't reel March
5th to go see the trader at film Inc I
don't know what that is if the wire was
a true story plus symbol again set in
Italy it would be this film ok the first
thing is it's nonsensical yeah that's a
horrible a movie theatre is the worst
place to go to outside of them in
Chinatown but it almost seems it almost
seems like that goes without saying
unfortunately that it was exactly said
yeah without saying we take the worst
place to go during a pandemic with a
virus that stems from China outside of
eating in Chinatown if you like you
wasted some syllables there ya didn't
have to say that it could have spelled
out plus we got it but no I have to say
it don't even Chinatown in case the
message isn't clear theaters movie
theaters are the worst place to go to
because you cannot manage distance at
all for 7-eleven the bathroom 7-eleven
bathrooms but that's that's always even
without pandemics right that's natural
occurring
their plumbing is less efficient than
the Romans history Roman timeline
because I always go through the timeline
try to make seem like Donald Trump did
nothing in de Blasio March 8th
that's after March 2nd so you think
March 8th it is you think in case you
didn't know the arc of this segment and
you're something that you know I'm not a
PD mala gist epidemiologist see that's
pretend almost Corral I'm not even then
when a virus spreads when there's like a
virus out we don't know a whole lot
about it yeah I would say well I'm not a
doctor but I'm pretty sure that since a
lot of people get it like you know it
could be transmitted through contact or
you should clean surface you have two
heads just a little right you don't need
to be a doctor to understand that right
well the thing is de Blasio is not a
doctor and he also doesn't understand
that because he said the Cova disappears
from surfaces in minutes like it was a
ShamWow commercial and then a couldn't
be transmitted through casual contact
what you need to really have some direct
contact you need to have the kind of
exposure that you wouldn't get casually
on the subway for example this is a
disease that does not live long on a
surface certainly on most surfaces like
metal plastic you know a desk a kitchen
counter a subway pole it's only a matter
of minutes before the disease dies and
the interpreter you saw he was saying
this I just I'm riding mr. Allsworth
gonna be here
and I usually try not take aim at that
singer from system of it down because
he's been through enough poison shank
denying so on the thing yes to clarify
because this is a silly show but let's
get serious for a second and only one
second coronavirus does remain on
services for a very long time
yeah it's really bad I want to be clear
provide you with some information of
course corona virus can be transmitted
just through casual contact we had dr.
Choi Maya my Korean doctor on the show I
believe two or three weeks ago to talk
about it and he did have this to say it
is my contact like if we shake the hands
of another person who has a virus or if
we actually touch the surfaces
soon after somebody who has a virus
touches a surface and then we touch our
face with it right because it enters
through our eyes or nose or mouth
so it's it's a respiratory virus but we
can also get it it can be airborne it's
typically not it can be airborne or
droplet so if somebody cops at us and
then we can actually inhale that and we
can get up we can get the virus
infection by the way he's also a
part-time signer Oh virus go in head
shoulders knees and toes I love dr. Cho
by the way he's gonna be on soon he's
the by the way hit the notification bell
we a ben shapiro coming up in a minute
um hit all notifications because
subscriptions don't necessarily mean a
whole lot
there's also crowd or bits now where you
can watch some segments and of course do
consider joining Mudd Club because uh
that's all we hear humph that's it it's
very sad when I think about if you don't
join uh promote we're dead Oh promo code
quarantine that's right thank you friend
a new content every day at 8 p.m. 8 p.m.
Eastern every day in case you can't be
bothered do you any of those things
let's look at the difference between
President Trump and mayor de Blasio
again he's a mayor of New York City it's
easy to forget so the media they said
that Trump downplayed this whole thing
when let's be honest
lately he's really just been trying to
give Americans hope he's been saying hey
we might be past the peak right now
there are things that we're doing there
treatments that might be working were on
the road toward a vaccine right hey
maybe we'll be open by Easter he said he
didn't open everything by Easter no
let's be really clear and let's contrast
that with de Blasio who was telling
people to get out there yeah and attend
public gatherings along with eating in
Chinatown delicious this entire time so
compare it hopefully it would be a
beautiful timeline if we could be open
on Easter Park can you believe this guy
and the other guys eating you know brat
on a strip nonetheless is down here in
charge no dentate mayor of New York this
really matters because it all now does
it show the blame game is just totally
playing politics whereas people say we
don't have time for politics like
governor Whitmer in Michigan I don't
have time for politics and she puts on
that hat that says that lady from lady
from Michigan haha you don't have time
for politics just time to audition for
Joe Biden's vice presidential hand
please so that hopefully you know people
don't think he's actually [ __ ]
they're not gonna buy it by the way
Julie so this matter that contrasts the
reaction time but also a fundamental
misunderstanding misinterpretation of
the role of government and this directly
relates to the Constitution so let me
explain this really quickly yes we know
that they all hate Donald Trump the
media we're talking about here right now
and I'm not his biggest fan but I think
that the pettiness the childishness is
this is karma yeah so good this is what
they deserve but again they freaked out
misrepresenting him saying that his
authority in allowing States to reopen
their own economies is absolute as John
King was just saying he's claiming that
he has authorities that he doesn't have
the Constitution does not give the
president United States total authority
David is the president's power total in
this clearly it's not total yeah let's
get her act advice from a three split
view with Axelrod and the Octomom he's a
voice that's needed so that can you
believe this he's a dictator
authoritarian he's saying that his
authority in allowing States to reopen
is absolute now let's compare this to
after all the downplaying after all that
it's not an emergency go eat in
Chinatown New York City shut everything
down after all this and the
whoa claimed that he has the power the
absolute power to permanently shut down
any church or synagogue that disobeys
his orders everyone has been instructed
that if they see worship surfaces going
services going on they will go to the
officials of that congregation to inform
them they need to stop the services and
disperse if that does not happen they
will take additional action up to the
point of fines and potentially closing
the building permanently closing Wow the
building permanently keep in mind to
that de Blasio is this is the guy who's
concerned that a Christian group that
might be helping and that they may not
be allowed to by the way did he mention
anything about Islamic places of worship
just the Jews that he chose to mention
Christians and Jews anti-semantic much
goes over very well in the Upper West
Side but this is remarkable to me for a
few reasons yeah the park thing there
was a guy who got fine for kissing his
wife in a park oh yeah
it's like people you do realize you guys
I'm gonna go have sex with her yeah I
choose my wife if we're gonna if it's
gonna get it's ridiculous that we're
social distancing at home no I keep
putting my kid in a different room my
wife's like you might drown we're not
trying because listen even I don't care
what the virus is you could bring back
SARS one I gets mine Larry
so where do they find someone in a
public park but this is yeah this to me
shows a fundamental in capability of
understanding the role of government
okay I think Donald Trump was wrong and
saying he has absolute authority not
rank in context it's not nearly as
severe as people make it out to be and
if you look at his actions they've
actually been pretty measured don't take
my word for it take Cuomo take newsome's
word for it right he didn't open things
at Easter he was hoping that we could
open things your answer
he hasn't reopened the entire economy
now he's hoping that we can he hasn't
signed some kind of an executive order
what he's saying is that he can end
effectively a Nash
shanell van on commerce that is
happening in allows States to real he
has absolute authority to defer it to
the states that is important compare
that with de Blasio who is there on
camera expressly communicating a
violation of the First Amendment saying
that he will shut down churches
permanently after you just said go down
and eat in Chinatown so churches are go
riding that big a deal you can't go in
case it's not as bad as Chinatown he is
saying that he would shut down churches
permanently let me be really clear
separation of church and state is a term
that's thrown around it's not actually a
real thing it's not an actual real
wording it's written from Jefferson to
the Danbury Baptist taken out of context
but when you look at the First Amendment
the spirit of it is very important
because it's about keeping the
government out of the church running
business why precisely to preserve the
church because they believe that for
immoral sassette for up for a free
society you had to have a moral Society
so they saw the importance of the church
and did not want to have a Church of
England that's not why it exists and
here you have a mayor not saying he has
the absolute authority to defer to
States in reopening their economies as
they see fit but you have a mayor of the
biggest city in the country saying hey I
am going to use my church to step into
the church running or synagogue business
and shut them down permanently if they
don't take my granted a conflicting
advice that is absolutely authoritarian
that is absolutely a violation of the
spirit of the Constitution and basic
American rights and it's actually a
violation of the letter of the
Constitution in basic American rights so
if we want to play the game and try and
try and go back and forth with semantics
I don't know you're the party of the guy
who said eat and shine it down and then
the next week said I will shut down
churches permanently unless you follow
my every order you have no leg to stand
on it's done we're not listening to you
let's look at the pluses and minuses and
get back to starting this economy if you
like this video subscribe or hit the
notification bell and hit all
notifications of course you can join mug
club at what
it's moving pictures talkies they're in
boxes they really do travel in boxes